[Music]
now you know
now you know
i'm about to undress please don't record
this
i've been thinking about this idea
recently it's a little goofy a little
over the top we're usually out on set in
the sunlight without access to power so
i was thinking you know instead of
getting those little usb battery packs
what if you had unlimited energy from
the sun i want to build a solar powered
sombrero aka the sunbrero we could use
that to power anything over a usb port
and that is where this idea really
starts taking off i saw this video a
couple years ago from the guys who make
the onewheel actually they posted this
april fools video called the solar
sombrero where they plugged it into
their one wheel the problem with that
video other than the fact that it's fake
is that there's not actually enough real
estate on a sombrero to power a onewheel
however there's plenty of real estate
there to power a cell phone or multiple
cell phones it might be a little bit
more practical just to have a big
battery bank in your pocket but that's
no fun i wanted to make something cool
and fun to use and also keep you nice
and cool and stylish you'll be the
coolest looking dude on the block
wearing this hat i guarantee it
making little cardboard cutouts to
represent solar panels that i might be
purchasing the first problem you run
into when doing this kind of project is
actually choosing which solar cells to
buy these are my pretend solar panels
i'm gonna put this on the hat and see
what i can uh arrange what i'm trying to
figure out is how many solar panels we
need to buy and by solar panels i mean
solar cells what people classically know
of as a solar panel is like the big
square panels right those produce you
know a decent amount a solar panel is
actually made of dozens of solar cells
each provides like five watts of power
or less what i need for this project is
to buy those individual solar cells and
make my own solar panel out of them size
is the most important issue for me
wow don't take that out of context
because the solar panel can be in
whatever orientation you want you just
wire up all the individual solar cells
together however you want but if you
want to have a sombrero you gotta change
it up a bit and that's what i'm here to
figure out is what exact orientation to
actually put these things in the solar
panels i'm looking at are like five
inches by six inches after doing a bunch
of research it basically came down to
two different options i can choose this
basically five by six inch cell or a two
by three inch cell the smaller cell
produces slightly less power per square
inch than the larger cell however
because it is smaller you can actually
put way more cells on a hat what i ended
up finding is that even with the higher
packing ratio of using the smaller cells
to pack in more of them on the hat it
still didn't make up for the amount of
power i was able to easily generate
using the bigger panels what i also kind
of want is from the front you can't tell
that i've got a solar powered hat until
i turn around oh don't mind me i'm just
you know charging my phone
so i think this will work because
there's half the number of panels it'll
require far less work to solder
everything together i think this might
be the way to go i wanted to thank
bombfell for sponsoring this video if
you don't know what bombfell is it's an
online personal styling service where
you can get all styled up with exactly
what you want there's no hidden fees
anything like that if you want to try it
out go to bombfeld.com salmoneco for 25
bucks off that being said my shipments
arrived can't wait to try it out here we
go
i'm going to embrace the corporate
millennial lifestyle and i'm going to go
to bombfell
b-o-m-b-fell.com complete wardrobe
makeover let's do it so when you sign up
for bombfell they ask you a bunch of
questions about what you like and what
you don't like and they also ask you
questions about what kind of style you
want to achieve it's fully personalized
because every piece is handpicked by a
personal stylist before anything is sent
the stylist shows you the clothes
they've picked out for you and if you
like them they send them if you don't
they'll pick out new ones so the service
is totally flexible you can push up
delay or skip shipments anytime i'm set
yeah awaiting close that's the next step
yeah close the window now you know
now you know
i'm about to undress please don't record
this ooh
all right i feel very excited we all
know that i'm terrible at picking up my
own clothes the only clothes i wear are
the stuff i help design generally so
it's like i've forgotten how to like
shop
i need bombs
damn i'm gonna put this stuff on this
stuff's pretty nice all right guys
fully naked on the sam and eco channel
again you know the first time i got nude
on this channel well we deleted that
video let's just sit down pants they fit
that's actually a first usually when i
get pants off on amazon they don't fit
pretty comfy i did pick slim as my fit
all right next up shirt a blue greenish
henley style shirt i didn't realize
these were called henley's for the
longest time all right here we go
just censored like the small nipple
areas
replace them with someone else's nipples
or something
yes damn sam shirt fits it's comfortable
we got one more piece it's nice having
some blue i have like a lot of red this
is gonna help mix my wardrobe up perfect
i got my hat
i'm in the office today and this is just
a little too casual for the opposite i
think i need that button up i think it
complements my look quite nice today i'm
popping these tags off yeah here we go
i'm keeping this everything fits really
well actually it's super comfy it looks
really nice i feel like i'm a little
more cultured now even though it's
winter we still are in california and
this shirt's just a little too warm even
for our cold weather so i don't think
i'll be needing this shirt which is
great because every box comes with a
return label and if there's something
you don't want just throw in the box and
i won't get charged for it perfect so if
you keep more you get more in each
shipment because the more you keep the
more you save four items are twenty
percent off three items are fifteen
percent off and two items are ten
percent so if you can't dress yourself
or don't have the uh energy too that's
bomfail.com
nico
are you previously a professional
skateboarder no it's cool i dig it i'm
glad i'm glad you guys finally respect
me now if you'd like to see the next
stage in sam's rise to fashion guru
consider subscribing yeah if you want to
see if we can accomplish anything up
here fix this up subscribe i don't think
they've invented anything for that yet
maybe we'll have to do that all right so
all the parts have arrived and now let's
lay them out and see what we've got a
usb power meter got some usb splitters
some usb powered fans this is actually
probably the most complicated aspect of
the setup are the usb 2 amp charge
controllers and of course some 22 gauge
wire this is gonna be the wiring that
holds all the panels together and of
course last but not least we got the
actual solar panels nick are you ready
for this you ready for the most
satisfying thing of your life
oh boy
i specifically chose cells that were 5
volts because that's the same voltage
that goes through a usb port the reason
why i went that route is because it
keeps the whole system simple i don't
have to do any fancy boosting of the
voltage or bucking of the voltage it
just goes straight into these little usb
plugs and straight into your phone
simple easy done i figured out the
layout i've got them all in place and
i've got the wire mostly in place too it
may look complicated but the wiring here
is actually fairly straightforward it's
just you got two big wires going around
the center with all the solar panels
feeding their energy into those two
wires and those two wires will now feed
into the usb ports
hi everybody just here to let you know
that i can't find the solder so ren's
going to go buy some
oh
i have soldered home and i meant to
bring it it was ready to go i wonder if
spencer won't mind if we borrow his
solder today he's going to mine he's
going to mine so hard
hey spencer
hey what's up hey man uh i'm working on
a cool little project um i have to get
this project done today
and i left my uh solder at home oh
i see what's going on
stealing solder
because somebody keeps using all my
solder i don't know who
but uh here here it is thanks man whoa
this is so thin yeah well thank you so
much yeah yeah
first thing first i just kind of put
solder on each of the positive and
negative terminals of each solar panel
some solar cells that you buy already
come with those cables attached i had to
wire them on myself which is easy enough
so it's not a big deal i am painting one
of the wires silver using a silver
sharpie so that i will know that this is
the positive cable and not the negative
cable the reason why i'm doing that is
because i want everything to be black or
silver on this hat after that i cut each
of the wires stripped the ends off to
expose the metal insides from there it's
just a simple matter of attaching those
wires to each of the solar panels but
now i've got these center wires going
around the hat that i need to connect
each of the solar panels to i would
expose the inside by pulling apart the
silicon covering over each of the
positive and negative wires going around
the hat and i would actually wrap the
metal end of the solar cell around that
and then add solder on top of
that was actually pretty satisfying
so for the past week and a half gabe and
i have been tasked with fancying
everything up back here making it pop
look nice that has included a lot of
painting hence
all this so we started with the hallway
we wanted to keep some of the minecraft
wall but we need to change things up you
know the universe moves toward change
and entropy so we have to destroy this
part of the minecraft wall and it's now
the art wall if you want your art on the
wall send it to us the pipes in the door
frames were a lighter blue they're now
dark blue to match the scheme out here
continuing the color scheme from outside
down into the hall so that connects it's
very nice we took everything off took
all the guns away took this off so it's
very fresh professional the
kudegra of the hall is the new
skateboard wall
so all of these are active boosted
boards electric skateboards we're still
finishing the charging station it's
gonna be a little more like functional
and presentable so these are just guitar
hooks hanging here that hold the boards
on we took these old crates that have
been in the studio forever painted them
to match the scheme and also
oh
made them functional so
batteries and whatnot through there
this one's got hoverboards
you know it's it's nice to have things
look nice but it's also nice to have
them be functional so this is a great
use of this space and also helps clean
things up and organize the storage so
that's great i literally just went one
cell at a time until i got through all
eight cells attached to that center wire
there
i got them i got all eight solar cells
soldered into the wire now the thing is
though is that they weren't actually
attached to the hat yet i didn't know if
i was going to need to maybe make any
changes to and i didn't want to have
them permanently mounted just yet sure
enough that was great because i ended up
needing to take them off to cut holes
for the usb splitter right in the front
of the hat once i got the usb splitters
in the hat i was able to put the solar
cells back onto it and then get it
roughly in the same spot it's all wired
and ready to go
after attaching all the solar cells
together the final step is to actually
hook it up to the power controller in
this case that's a usb port but here's
the thing i had two usb ports to choose
from so i needed to evenly distribute
the power by basically splitting the end
of each of the positive and negative
terminals into two points that is where
the red wire comes into and the reason
why i use the red wire is because i ran
out of black wire i took a couple extra
wires attached each of the usb ports
together i used the same splicing
technique i did for the solar cells
themselves to the wires that connected
the two usb ports together and that
effectively made a splitter for the
power i had all the solar cells
connected all the energy going through
the wire and then splitting off to the
two usb ports
and i'm done i think with wiring anyway
next step is to actually test it this is
the most exciting part is the testing
well first let's test it with the light
in here what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
apply this power meter and maybe there's
enough light from the lamps here and the
skylight that will actually get a charge
and we'll find out by plugging it in
there's not enough charge
hold on let me try
this it powered on
powered on it is providing five volts
okay that part's working i put in the
fan
it uh stopped working come on power
power
power of the lamp it's not working okay
i'm gonna bring both fans uh and let's
go outside and see how this works okay
here i am in the shade i'm gonna go
ahead and plug in my power meter
already i'm getting the voltage and i'm
in the shade right now and i'm just
gonna plug this in
i can kind of feel it vibrating it's
wanting to work but nothing's happening
plug this in
it's working if i go in the sun
nothing should change really oh man that
is okay that's that's good that is
working hard man my wiring worked
oh my gosh it works i feel the breeze
this is nice man let's see if this works
and it works it works it does work so
it's charging my phone now from the sun
i honestly think this build is a pretty
good success but the next test here is
to see how well it works on an actual
real film set we have that walking dead
shoot coming up that's gonna be outside
so we can test this here
it works
it works
awesome look at this oh my gosh
oh that's nice yeah it feels pretty good
charging my phone right now off the
other port
fashion trend with that dude don't you
know it
now can you set up a version where you
plug it into your car and see if it can
charge your car hey that's the next
project
this is really cool i like this a lot
ren we're connected
thank you check your own phone i don't
have it on me but i'll put it in my
pants like i do what am i charging
nobody knows
something sexy sorry if you got
demonetized dude how do you feel about
that fan power though i really like the
fan power let me do some poses for you
oh
hello there oh yeah oh here you go that
is so nice you're riding your one wheel
while playing your switch and charging
at the same time
so if you don't mind me asking how much
did this whole hat cost to make is like
70 80 bucks it's not bad that's it yeah
where can we get them danny cordora
digital.com coming soon pre-order yours
today that's already a website oh yeah
okay well
900.
sunbrella ooh that's much better
sunbrero even in the shade i can power
these fans the last run because the
corridor purge we've finally gotten rid
of the overflow we're even getting rid
of a full master chief costume but we've
gotten rid of everything that we needed
to kind of just reset the studio and
kick off 2018 with a fresh start last of
it
if you want to see us improve more on
the studio get more cool gear and fill
up all the empty gaps we just made
subscribe to sam niko channel
i am pretty excited about this idea but
here's the thing i have so many other
ideas for other projects to build so if
you happen to make or produce solar
panels of some sort hit us up i'd love
to work together